vladimir putin ha viajado a kaliningrado
un enclave ruso que está aislado del
resto del país por tierra y que ahora
con la guerra sufre todavía más ese
aislamiento en su agenda visitar una
escuela naval y dar una charla sobre
derechos humanos pero el punto más
importante es la reunión con el
gobernador con antón alija no para
hablar de los problemas de tránsito que
tiene ahora mismo que han emigrado
porque desde el inicio del verano
lituania que es el país que está entre
kaliningrado y el resto de rusia impide
el tránsito de algunas mercancías por
ferrocarril es el caso de los materiales
de construcción que empiezan a faltar ya
en kaliningrado y mientras putin viaja a
la zona en el país vecino a kaliningrado
en polonia ambos comparten fronteras
cunde la inquietud precisamente por ese
viaje no es nada de extrañar puesto que
ocurre cada vez debido sobre todo a las
tensiones y las malas relaciones que
tienen no sólo polonia sino los países
bálticos con rusia